bonjour laurent alexandre merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt français de
répondre à nos questions alors lé
résultat provisoire d'une enquête
commandée par le ministère belge de la
santé ont démontré que des agents
présents sur les masques livré par la
société ave rocks pourraient être nocifs
pour la santé n'est pas votre avis pour
quelle raison il ya eu peu de masques
qui ont été produits et ils ont été
achetés et commandé par le gouvernement
belge dans l'urgence au printemps au
moment où tout le monde manquée de
masques
donc le gouvernement n'a pas fait sa
chochotte n'a pas fait sont difficiles
parce que souvenez vous il ya un an
la pénurie de masques étaient absolument
dramatiques et tout le monde se battait
pour avoir des masques alors on réalise
qu'il y à quelques dérives et
argentiques et et titanic dans les
masques mais ce sont de toutes petites
quantités sur des masques qui ont été
utilisés plus peu de temps le risque
qu'il y ait dans le futur des cancers
chez les gens qui ont porté ces masques
et absolument insignifiant il faut
savoir aujourd'hui que on a des mesures
de dosage des composants chimiques
tellement feeling qu'on est capable de
devoir des quantités absolument
infinitésimale de produits y compris des
doses qui ne sont pas toxiques tôt qu'il
ne faut pas que les gens s'inquiètent il
faut bien sûr ne pas utiliser ces
masques mais franchement il n'y a pas de
quoi s'inquiéter pour sa santé ou la
santé de ses proches
alors si l enquête venait à démontrer
que la toxicité de ces masques et si les
masques représentant un vrai danger pour
les millions de belges qui s'en sont
procurés quelle solution le gouvernement
est il en mesure d'apporter s'il y avait
eu un composé vraiment cancérigènes aux
doses où il est où il existe dans dans
les masques il faudrait une surveillance
des patients dans le futur mais vraiment
nous n'en sommes pas là nous sommes en
train de pousser le principe de
précaution à son extrême limite
personnellement j'ai déjà eu recours à
ses basques et je n'ai pour ma santé
personnelle absolument aucune inquiétude
par rapport à l'utilisation de ces
masques qu'il faut bien évidemment
retirer puisque nous avons un léger
doute mais nous ne sommes pas du tout
dans une phase où il faut être inquiète
vraiment ne crée
on pas une psychose sur ces minuscules
quantités d'argent et de titane dans les
masques il vaut mieux d'ailleurs porter
ces masques là que de ne rien porter
pour sa santé parce que le risque des
dérivés argentique et au tennis et au
titane qu'il y a dans les mains à ce qui
est insignifiant par rapport au risque
d'attraper le coc vide quand on n'a pas
de masque du tout alors il ya une
enquête qui avait été ouverte au
printemps dernier sur l'attribution du
contrat de livraison des masques groupe
av rock selon vous pourquoi les
autorités ne décident que maintenant
bien l'attirer de marché écoutez vous
voyez bien que nous sommes depuis 1
heure dans une phase très difficile
politiquement les gouvernements sont
submergés ils doivent accepter des
couvre-feux déconfinement qui sont
liberticides et que la population ne
supporte plus d'autre part l'europe ne
sort pas des couvre-feux de confinement
partie ce qu'elle a complètement raté
son plan vaccinal puisque c'est en
europe qu'il y a le moins de doses de
vaccin au moment où israël au moment où
l'angleterre sont en train d'ouvrir de
réouvrir les libertés parce qu'ils ont
bien avancé dans la vaccination
on arrive en israël à 100 vaccination
pour 100 habitants 1
donc israël va tout ré ouvrir dans les
semaines qui viennent les gouvernements
européens sont face à une pression
populaire très très très forte
donc ils sont submergés et le dossier
des masques n'était pas sur le haut de
la pile pour les autorités sanitaires le
belge et je le répète c'est quelque
chose de tout à fait compréhensible
franchement ce n'est pas l'enjeu et il
ne faut pas hystériser le débat à ce
point je n'ai personnellement aucune
inquiétude quant à la toxicité de de ces
masques oui parce que le ministre de la
santé un frank vandenbrouck lui assure
que vaut mieux prévenir que guérir
qui il affirme également qu'il n'existe
pas de preuves de nocivité sur ces
masques et ils estiment que leur retrait
de la circulation est en fait je cite
par souci de prudence et on en est là
exactement
on est dans une phase où par prudence on
prend des précautions exagérées et on
crée d'ailleurs des inquiétudes chez les
gens parce que cette affaire de masque
on aurait mieux fait de ne pas en parler
les quantités de métaux sont vraiment
infinitésimale et ne présentent pas de
risque pour la santé de mon point de vue
en tant que citoyen et en tant que
médecin et on a semé le doute dans la
population on a un qui étaient les gens
dans la dans la phase de psychose
sanitaire nous sommes en ce moment ce
n'est peut-être pas la peine d'en
rajouter de compte tenu du retard du
programme vaccinal européen
les européens en général et les belges
en particulier vont devoir subir des
mois et des mois de couvre-feu et de
confinement encore donc ne rajoutons pas
des dé source d'angoissés et de
dépression
ça sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
laurent alexandre d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et je rappelle que vous êtes
essayiste et chirurgiens à bruxelles